nbc sports boston's tom curran here on
the rich eisen show how are you tom
tremendous i am tremendous richard how
are you i am doing fine
um let's jump in with both feet here tom
because
we've been i mean we spoke all
throughout the spring and summer of what
things are going to look like in new
england and you were saying um
it's stidham's job stidham's job there
is there is nobody else there
um and uh we got kind of you know caught
off guard
because it was them's job all the way
through to late june and it's still not
stedham's job even with cam
uh winning only six of the first 13 or
the patriots winning six of the first 13
with
the season going the way that it is um
are you surprised by belichick's
response
that it's still cam's gig for the rest
of the way now
i hate to see him a little contrarian
but no and here's the reasons why i'm
not surprised go for it
the patriots made a commitment to cam
and they've asked them to do an awful
lot for a million bucks
they brought him in at the end of june
he has been a franchise stabilizer he's
been a perfect bridge in terms of
leadership from tom brady
bill belichick and josh mcdaniels know
the limitations of their offense
and the quote-unquote weaponry around
cam
so they send him out there with less
than
around him they put a lot on his plate
he didn't have an off-season he's got
opt-outs
uh on both sides of the ball that he's
dealing with and as a result
i think the bill would perceive it as
look i put spider-man
who really hasn't done a lot to impress
us since cam arrived especially
during training camp when there was for
a few days a little bit of an open
competition
that would seem as if i'm putting the
blame for this on cam and i'm not going
to do that
i'm going to remain loyal to him because
he's done everything we've asked of them
including a stretch after they started
two and five where they played pretty
good
and he played pretty good so that's
where i think it all stems from that's
the reluctance
rich so what is the future of the
quarterback position for new england
then tom what do you think
i think it's ryder die with cam until
the team's eliminated and then
if bill decides and i could see him
still being stubborn enough to not do it
because
the wolves and the media and the um
folks in the stands or on in from their
televisions not in the stands
are screaming for jared said we're just
not i'm gonna do it my way
just go with cam but i cannot imagine
that cam newton would be
any kind of a long-term answer next year
and i'd be stunned if he's back
in a roll unless that's a game you want
to come back no one's giving you
something
kind of signing that happens in june as
for stinhum i would say he's probably
going to be in the mix
with whoever the team either drafts
trades for or signs
at the quarterback position but you're
going into a gunfight with a spoon
with cam newton as a quarterback in 2020
when you get behind you can do great
things for your team
relative to if you're ahead and the game
is being played on your terms
but if those terms are not friendly to
you
your hands are tied so let's get into a
little bit of why
a great line by the way going into a
gunfight with a spoon
um why the patriots are only armed with
a
spoon i know you were somewhat vocal
because i follow you and follow your
work tom curran from out here in
southern california that when bill
belichick said
that there was a price to pay
essentially
for uh selling out over the last several
years to win super bowls before brady
would eventually leave and they thought
he would probably still stay
um that that's part of the reason why
there's a spoon on the field
or they're arming the patriots with less
than
this year your thoughts on all of this
you can't escape the draft
and that's where you're supposed to go
shopping for your artillery
and if you're in the flatware aisle rich
and you're coming home with spoons
you're going to end up having a fight
with spoons and that's really what has
happened especially in the offensive
side of the ball
since really about 2014 they just
haven't done well in the draft and and
you have to eventually
pay the cost and when the patriots
ignore the tight end position in the
draft
and don't acquire anyone through free
agency you're left with
two rookies who are panic buys in the
2020 draft and can't practice with the
team because of a pandemic
and neither is relevant so you're
basically taking the field without a
tight end
and asking a guy who you signed at the
end of june
to make do i mean the patriots in 2017
traded jimmy garoppolo on halloween did
then what they do with the quarterback
position well they held the door open
for tom brady
and tapped their foot until he finally
walked through it
and they signed to a drafted danny
upling and jared stidham
so what's on the field right now and i
know that bill belichick
who i've covered for his entire period
of time in new england
is maybe not just the greatest coach of
the super bowl era or an nfl history
he might be the greatest coach in
american professional sports history
be that as it may they haven't stocked
the team very well and that's why
they're running around the spoon
so uh what's the fix here because i mean
you know we're we we should assume that
you know i think
hopefully thank to the gods that this
vaccine
is going to do what we all hope and it
will go in as many arms as we all hope
and it will actually
end this pandemic and thus 2021 will be
as close to
normal football season as we can
remember that
some of the players that opted out will
be in and won't have such diminishing
returns after sitting out for a year
and then what uh you got to find a new
quarterback and then what
like what's the fix here for new england
as
they move into 2021 and into the final
several years
of the brilliant coaching career of bill
belichick what do you think tom
glass half full you have about 60
million dollars worth of cap space
available which is
third or fourth depending upon who's
doing the bookkeeping highest in the nfl
we'll see what the cap ends up being but
the patriots are well primed to do some
good shopping
if they can get the right guys the right
spots
glass half empty not only do you have to
draft well and address a quarterback
position when you might probably be
around 15 or
you know anywhere between 10 and 16 in
the draft
you have to hit that spot you also have
guys like james white
jason mccourty and lawrence guy and adam
butler and david andrews and joe tooney
all coming up on contracts as well so
that's 60 million dollars that you're
looking at is
in your hot little hand ready to shop
for free agents there's some key key
players on this team
who may not be back never mind patrick
chung and dante hightower who both took
this year off because of covid marcus
cannon
uh they might just be getting warmed up
and what we've seen this year you know
this quote as well as anybody
was said about don shul or bear bryant
but it was said
he can take his in and beat urine and he
can take urine and beat his
and bill belichick can still do that and
he's done that this year
you know if you look at last week
against san diego 45 to nothing that's a
pretty talented team that got absolutely
depends
because the patriots on special teams
defense and with a game plan they could
execute on offense and kill them
but when you get in against a more
talented team that's well coached and
has a plan
like we saw last night you're going to
be in for it because the team is not
that
over the top talented okay so
uh i i guess and as we begin to wrap
this up tom curran nbc sports boston i i
i think this has a feel of a week 14
post mortem on a patriot season which
is very strange to me i don't i don't
believe i've ever done this because the
last time they had seven losses was
the year before nfl network began i
don't think i've ever done something
like this
and um it's weird i'm not gonna lie it's
just weird
right now yeah it's new to me too i mean
i thought that they would go eight and
eight and miss the playoffs
um and that was after they acquired cam
but it is weird because
the tenor of bill i was just
communicating with somebody on twitter
who dm me about i said look bill is
basically
saying to fans you don't like it
in media tough crap i gave you a lot of
fun enjoyment for the last 20 years
it's not that great right now but i'm
trying to fix it you just shut up and
wait for the entertainment i'll provide
it when i can
so sit there like i mean he said this
morning i'm not going to answer
the question again about quarterback um
he is taking on a role of i'll have to
answer to you people
which i get i do and do you get that i
mean to a degree
of the mindset rich you know pretty well
no doubt and i i
i mean i i got to sit next to him for
for two days and hear the way that he
thinks and
and all of that you know but uh i i
would never presume
to ever think though you know that i
know
exactly what's in his mind but i do know
you know his level of pride and i do
know that he's been around the block and
he's
he could probably sit here and recall
the time this happened in 1988 or
you know what he read about in 1954 and
how this
worked here and that worked there and
i'll get it fixed in this way but you're
right like at some point
though it's got to be dk metcalf and not
nikhil harry it's got to be
nick chubb and not sony michelle
although that might not be very fair
because sony michelle in the super bowl
year was
dynamite in that postseason i mean he
was he was a difference maker in many
different ways when
when when points i mean there's so much
gray area and he'd acknowledge that and
that's what he would present you with
okay so
you know we threw a screen to damien
harris and aaron donald grabbed him and
it's an anticipatory screen to get
return for a pick six that made it 17
nothing
and then after that they only scored
seven points what do you want from us
bad we didn't do well okay what else
but i mean it's um he is not
as he has said a couple of times this
year in the business of defending
himself
which is fine he's not in the business
of apologizing which is fine
but i think even an open give and take
on where the team is
why it's here and where it's headed he
will not countenance
richard before i let you go tom karn
you've been covering bill belichick
every single uh day since he's arrived
in new england you've seen this you've
seen him you've been around the block
with him
so uh what do you think that we know
that he doesn't think that that cam
deserves to be in there and we know
he's he's he probably has evaluated stit
him enough
that that we can understand and for real
know
that um he's not evaluating stidhum in
week 17
when he starts them against the winless
jets he's doing that specifically
along with all the other guys that he'll
throw out there from the practice squad
make sure that the jets
don't get trevor lawrence your thoughts
when it's all done week 17 how does that
happen
that the jets the jets are one loss away
that the jets are one loss away
from clinching trevor lawrence and the
man standing in their way
or maybe being able to step out of the
way
is bill belichick what do you think he
does with that four-dimensional
chessboard
tom what do you think that's a great
sophie's choice isn't it because you can
either go with
i really want to see this franchise go
down
with the ignominious fact that they have
an owen 16 around that's one
so that argues to to hit the tape all
the way through
um boy that's a that's a great question
because i know he likes gays too does he
want to have saddle games with that but
he's never like
i don't want to finish seven and nine
either that's true
so that's holy crap but you stick people
up after christmas
you sit you kind of pull the foot off
the gas pedal which goes against
every fiber of his being but if you do
that
right you put the jets at one in 15 and
just maybe uh you don't see
trevor lawrence twice a year and the
jets don't get the best
most talented player potentially in the
draft in the last some odd
years that that's coming down to pike
thomas okay i'm i'm putting that on to a
quick document word so i can have that
for a story to write later
because i think
hey you're welcome that's what i see
i've tried to make my guests better from
when i said hello that's what i'm trying
to do here thank you my friend
you take care of yourself tom thanks for
the call all right buddy take care thank
you guys it's tom curran
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here